-Welcome back to the show, bud.
-My bro.
-It's always good to see you,
and it's great to have you
back in person, too.
-I know, man.
-I appreciate this.
Thank you very much.
-No, thank you, thank you.
Thanks for having me.
-The last time you did our show,
you did it from your home.
and I appreciate that
you did that for us.
But now, here,
we have a full audience.
-Oh, but this is
much better, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's much better
being here, man.
-Yeah. You didn't slow down
during the pandemic.
-Oh, no.
-You released two albums.
You just got nominated for
two Latin Grammys yesterday.
-Latin Grammys. Yeah.
-Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-That's what I'm talking about,
man.
I love that.
-Thank you, man. Yeah.
Super-excited.
-How different is it
writing during the pandemic
than what you have
written before?
-Well, I didn't stop
working, man.
You know, I went to the studio.
I have a studio there
in my house,
remember,
that I was telling you?
-I love that.
-And that I have the elevator
that goes straight to
the studio.
-Dude, I got to go there, man.
-So, yeah, like, during
the pandemic and everything,
the only thing
that I did, like, literally
was just waking up in my pj's,
just going straight to
the studio and making music.
That's how I actually made
two albums in one year, man.
-That's crazy.
That's a lot of work.
-Yeah, I did
"7DJ (7 Días en Jamaica)"
and then I did
"Papi Juancho" also.
And, well, "Hawái" --
that was, like, my main song,
one of the biggest songs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right.
-It's the one that is nominated
to the Latin Grammys.
And we just won two
Billboard Awards, too,
with "Hawái."
So it was a weird year for me,
but, at the same time, it was
pretty productive, you know?
-Yeah, it was very fruitful.
Yeah.
-It was just beautiful, too.
-I've read up
a little bit about you
and I saw that
you started writing music
because you were in school
and you would write
for your friends,
who were trying to get girls.
And they were like, "Hey,
will you write something for me?
Like, write me a poem or song or
something I can give to girls."
Is that true?
-That's true, bro.
-Wow!
-Oh, that's crazy.
-And then what?
And then you go, "Wait,
I should do this for a living."
-I know. I know.
-I mean, you're going to
end up being Maluma.
-I know.
-It's like, "Wow."
-I saw that all of the
relationships
that my friends they had --
they were working out
with my poems, you know,
with my letters and everything.
I was like, "[Bleep] like,
I should do this for a living."
-Yeah, yeah. Why not?
-And then I started composing
music and everything,
and here we are.
-Yeah. And you're finally
back on the road.
-Yeah, man.
-This is a big deal.
This is the "Papi Juancho Tour."
"Papi Juancho Tour," man.
-I love "Papi Juancho."
What is "Papi Juancho?"
It makes me want to get --
-Well, my family and friends --
they call me Juancho
because my name
is Juan Luis, right?
So, Juancho is, like, a nickname
for Juan in Colombia.
And then I saw a lot of fans --
they were texting me and
they were putting on my Twitter
like "Papi" or "Daddy Juancho"
or whatever.
-Yeah, I bet, I bet, I bet.
-Whatever it was.
And -- I don't know.
It just sounded, like, cool --
"Papi Juancho."
-Yeah, I like "Papi Juancho."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It does sound good.
"Papi Juancho"!
-And that's how we
created the whole concept
and the whole album
and the tour.
Yeah, man.
-Yeah. And you're gonna be --
You're playing
Madison Square Garden on Friday.
-This Friday, yeah.
-That's wild.
-Finally, finally again,
after two years, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Going back on tour is --
It feels great.
-You got to film a scene at
Madison Square Garden,
'cause -- We talked about this.
You're in this movie,
"Marry Me," with Jennifer Lopez
that comes out in February.
-Yeah.
-And it was supposed to
come out long ago.
-You're part of
the movie, too, huh?
-Yeah, I snuck in a little bit.
Yeah, yeah.
I was like, "Please, please put
me in this movie," yeah.
But, dude, you're a good actor.
-Yeah, man, I loved it.
-I'm glad we got to do
a scene together.
But what was it
like not acting with me,
but Jennifer Lopez or --
-With you, it was great, man.
-Yeah.
I'm sure it was
a lot of pressure
working -- acting with me.
-Oh, yeah. I felt the pressure.
-Thank you, yeah.
I'm a serious actor.
But what was Owen like?
Was he --
-He was great, man.
You know, that was like the
first time that
I was doing a movie, you know?
And Jennifer -- she called me.
She wanted me
to be part of the project.
So, it's, like, my first movie,
and it's a Hollywood movie
with Jennifer,
and, well, we have an
amazing casting, too.
So, bro, it's just like,
yeah, good news, positive vibes
happening right now.
-Everything's happening for you.
-Yeah.
-You're a good guy.
You're a good guy.
-Thank you, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We see the light.
-Yeah, exac--
Dude, you are the light, man.
And I got some pictures of you
I wanted to show you
and just walk through how --
-Pictures of me?
-Yeah, I got --
-Why you got pictures, though?
-No, but I think --
'Cause you have good fashion.
You got a good look.
And I want to talk about
some of these looks.
Look at this little guy.
-Oh, my God.
-He's a stud.
Now, that's probably what?
You're probably 12, 13?
-That's terrible.
-That's not terrible.
Lookit -- he's got
a popped collar.
-Bro, what kind of color
is that?
Like, a green?
-Tennis-ball green. Tennis...
[ Laughter ]
Tennis ball.
"Does this shirt come in
tennis ball?"
-I'm pretty sure that
sweater wasn't mine.
Maybe it was, like,
my sister's or whatever.
-Look at this guy.
This is your first album,
I want to say.
-Yeah.
-So, you're doing --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What I like about this is,
you got the shirt,
but then you got
the suspenders there, too.
That was interesting.
-Bro, bro, thank God
we're changing.
-We're evolving. We're evolving.
-We're evolving, man, yeah.
-But this one, I was like,
"When did Maluma --"
When did you have long hair?
-Let me see.
Wow. Wow.
I don't know if I
really like it, though. Wow.
-I like that guy.
He's mysterious to me.
-Yeah?
-Yeah, I don't really
understand what he's like.
-Like "Lion King" or something.
All that hair.
-You do have kind of
a big announcement
to make tonight
regarding fashion.
-Yeah, man. Yeah, yeah.
I'm so excited,
because I've been
working on this
for a while already.
So, I'm going to have my first
clothing collection
with Macy's, man.
It's gonna be amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Maluma...
-Amazes.
-Is it called Maluma?
-Royalty.
-It's called Royalty?
-Royalty. Royalty by Maluma.
-Dude, you're just crushing it.
-And that's
a nice collaboration.
I always dreamed about it,
and now it's actually happening.
-It's becoming a reality.
-Yeah.
-See? You're making
it happen, bud.
-Thank you, man.
-I want to play a game with
you -- is that okay? --
when we come back.
-Please, come on.
-Yeah. Here we go. Come on.
We're gonna play
"One Word Songs"
with Maluma after the break.
Come on back, everybody.